how many
men
especially let's say rich men you see
that in young girls actually wife the
younger girl like not a man in his 30s
mid-30s going on 40 like probably like
okay they say my 30's going down
how many of them do you see actually
look at jason beyonce what's it what's
the age difference
right
that that's generally
when
women are attracted to older men
this has always been like that
and men are attracted to younger women
i'm 25 i'd probably date someone up to
like 45. okay let's say this maybe i
have limitations maybe
i've
dated
okay let me give what's his name
leonardo dicaprio something like that
yeah he just loves to date younger girls
but he's never going to wife them
he wouldn't i'm not saying never but he
doesn't look like he's going to at this
point yeah he looks like he's having fun
yeah like he's just enjoying and these
girls are like 21 23
maybe i think the oldest i've ever heard
was 25
stretching it but wow
but i get why you all date young women
to keep yourself you know lively what
does that show you though
doesn't it show you that older men can
definitely bag younger women oh hundred
percent but then older women can't
generally bag younger men
i feel like that's changing now no
that's just the cougar
yeah i mean
what's the thing is changing now i feel
like
there are younger men that
are attracted to older women because of
as a younger man i would have had sex
with an older woman yeah just to say i
had sex with an older girl you know she
was oh my god she was like 10 years old
because she probably knows a lot more so
it's blowing his mind he's not going
anywhere but she's not a relationship
it's not a wife it's not long term those
you're kind of paying him to be there
let's say yeah you're mothering him too
your mother in to be there like you've
got the money he ain't get he so he's a
sugar baby he's a sugar baby and some
guys
and they'll stay they'll stay for a
sugar baby but they won't stay for
anything after that they'll be like oh
if a older woman was to a younger man
like oh
i want a relationship they're like
hmm
and she's an older woman feels younger
when she's touching the younger man
mm-hmm
she's like oh my god it makes me feel so
young yeah that's what i always say
speaking of this it reminds me of um
angela and what's her face 90 day fiance
oh you talking about the young boy
and she had oh no i was thinking about
another one
there's a there's a lady who has a
special nissan and she got she's like 48
and she got like the 25 to 23
i'm just thinking of angela and i don't
even know his name i don't know his name
but i know his face very round he's also
bold sorry sorry um
the one the one where he said oh you got
a little big but i still love you that
one i don't even i don't know
but angela angela 90 day fiance she went
to do surgery all of that that one
she got with this guy
and they're together they've been
married all of that he don't even want
to leave his country for her but he
wants a kid but he wants a kid
she's a doctor she can't give him she is
but it's so messed up i think you're
describing it i haven't seen it but what
you're describing is a desperate woman
because yeah yeah she is she's
describing the destruction the mere fact
you would be on 90 day fiance says a lot
yeah honestly you know what i mean
anyway i've said before marriage has
become a joke the fact that you can make
a tv show
called 90 day fiance out of marriage and
it's a tv show then you've got what is
it love at first sight
marriage shows yeah
people don't care about marriage
nowadays i feel like it's a game show
profitable thing to challenge love
to challenge someone's
capability with being with someone else
like
how can you say there's this one called
ultimatum you're with a partner yes and
now you have three weeks to live with
someone else
and
decide if you want to get married to the
partner you came with first
and that alone i said this is a disaster
i'm gonna sorry what so the creators of
love blind nicholas shea
nicholas shea and his wife they created
another show called the ultimatum so
these couples come in
and whichever person the man or the
woman gives the other person an
ultimatum either you
marry me at the end of these three weeks
that you're with somebody else so they
are connected with another person for
three weeks after those three weeks you
can either choose to come on as a couple
yes they come on as a couple and then
the then you go and see someone else yes
there's someone else that you're
connected with you can either stay with
that person
after the experiment or you can leave
and go with the other person and get
married to that person yeah but so you
stay with your current partner or get
married to the new person no no you
marry your current partner after the
three weeks or you leave your current
partner no matter how long you've been
together five years four years and you
go with this new person that you've
known for three weeks so you willingly
go on the show to give your partner to
somebody else
yeah just get out get out of here do you
know what's so funny about this
was um the only couple that was
genuinely going to get married i think
the guy was like
in his early 30s and she was like you
know the white guy was from texas or
something okay yeah yeah yeah they
seemed more logical because she was sick
the woman she was like i don't want no
one here except from you so i don't know
what i'm doing here like she did
something
yeah exactly she did tell one guy she
was interested in him but she was like i
could [ __ ] on you because you're
just a mess
but everyone else on the show was
literally 26 27 going down to 21. so i
was thinking your relationship is not
going to last anyway so they're just
young
and you can't get a grown person to be
on that show and think that's a smart
idea yeah but that it just shows the
mentality of the people is social it's
like social conditioning
for younger people to think that's okay
that it's
feasible if you go on a show like that
you're basically setting yourself up for
failure do you get one there's one girl
on there
she's the one who gave the ultimatum to
her boyfriend is the
black girl yeah with the tall light skin
him yeah
he was
he wasn't ready
she taught like not even that he wasn't
ready she's not ready technically but
she's the one that gave him the
ultimatum and in the end they broke up
and she ended up getting into a lesbian
relationship
[Music]
oh my god oh if you look at that dynamic
for you to go on that show
your relationship is already failing
because you know you know why you're
going on the show you you're either
you're a woman trying to force a man
into marriage with you which is
something that's in the back of your
mind like why hasn't he married me yet
really think about it and then and then
as a man
you're putting him in an arena
potentially to be with somebody else so
you already know the answer if my woman
came to me says there's a show babe yeah
it's called this and this is i said
tell me what you want to tell me right
now to talk about a show what is it that
you want right now exactly you ain't got
to take me on no damned show to tell me
automate him exactly tell me now if not
and just shut up so you already know the
answer when you're going on the show and
it shows that your your relationship is
fragile you're putting your relationship
under more pressure
to prove a point and that point might
lead to you losing your relationship
you're getting almost money yeah what
did they pay them yeah they must pay
them yes
i don't know but they just get paid get
paid i do have a question
do you what did you say i said they make
money
yeah they make money afterwards do you
think
i'll just say the two ladies that we've
been talking about
if cardi b and sierra were just
regular everyday women like us do you
think that they would be married right
now no
no no definitely yes russell wilson
russell wilson wouldn't be in the same
arena
i know i'm not saying to the people that
they're married to i'm just saying